with required mass now in Miami
President Trump now says he would wear a
mask in public around other people he
also says he wants another coronavirus
stimulus package without a program that
gives unemployed Americans an extra $600
a week in benefits has been Tracie
reports this comes as the president
still downplays the pandemic I think
we're going to be very good with the
corona virus I think that at some point
that's going to sort of just disappear I
hope President Trump is repeating the
same thing he said four months ago it's
going to disappear one day it's like a
miracle it will disappear he's put
together a revolutionary a first-class
team that is going to break through
bureaucracy and get us a vaccine but dr.
Anthony Fauci has warned that America is
headed towards 100,000 cases per day and
that we are still months away from a
vaccine wear a mask to slow the spread
the coronavirus task force is begging
Americans to wear masks president has
refused to wear one in public except for
when he was required to while visiting a
Ford plant in Michigan but after
pressure from Republican lawmakers in
Fox News the president now says this I'm
all for masks I think masks a good I
would wear if I were in a group of
people and I was close but he doesn't
think they should be mandatory the
president is also commenting for the
first time on camera about reports that
Russia paid bounties to have American
troops killed in Afghanistan I think
it's a hoax I think it's a hoax by the
newspapers and the Democrats but US
officials were concerned enough that
they shared the information with US
forces and allies in Afghanistan and CBS
News has learned the intelligence was
included in the president's classified
briefing material although it's not
clear he read them and this morning CBS
News has confirmed through a senior
Afghan official that the Russians were
involved in taking bounties out on US
soldiers now according to this official
the Russians quote achieved some of
their goals and they keep trying gale
all right Ben thank you very much